More than 800 cases nationwide, 300 plus of those fatal, and every day three more
cases are identified, and yet still
surprisingly few people are familiar
with the acquired immune deficiency
syndrome
or the acronym by which it's frequently identified AIDS.
Federal health officials consider it an epidemic yet you rarely hear a thing about it.
At first it seemed to strike only one segment of the population.
Now our Barry Peterson tells us this is no longer the case.
Music
In the mid-80s the magnitude the AIDS
crisis really started to hit home.
We saw some of our most creative people taken away from us by this terrible disease.
I just became increasingly convinced
that I had to do something.
But unfortunately at the time people didn't
believe in combinations for viruses.
We had already combinations of course for TB and for cancer.
But nobody believed you really need the combination for viral infections.
In fact some people, famous scientists, came to me when they saw my work,
and said great work, but you know we'll never see any combination chemotherapy for antivirals.
On the very first shot, we saw something absolutely amazing.
The synergy between AZT, in those
patients, and lamivudine or FTC
was an enormous breakthrough and led to the first combination drug Combivir.
That was the first time looking through
CDC's weekly morbidity & mortality reports
where there was a downward deflection in the death line.
It was absolutely correlatable.
Short of my wedding and the birth of my children, this was the most euphoric moment in my entire life,
is when I saw the data presented that showed that the majority of people who were started
on a three drug regimen their viral load felt undetectable
and their t-cell counts actually came up.
I was on Combivir, which was AZT and 3TC, or AZT and lamivudine with crixivan.
I showed a remarkable recovery.
I became undetectable and had my t-cells above 200.
Right now, I don't know, they're in the 600 range. I've been undetectable ever since.
The therapy that came out at that time was literally a lifesaver.
I'm 35 years old and I've been living
with HIV for all but six weeks of my life.
In my childhood I was told that I was going to die.
Then when I didn't and I did graduate high school it was kind of this unexpected adulthood.
What do I do now? I guess I'll go to college.
So it was no longer a death sentence.  HIV was no longer a death sentence.
That was an amazing change because mortality dropped from 72% of people who have HIV
to less than 25%, very rapidly, thanks to HAART therapy.
Music